what
crazy i'm david marquet former nuclear
submarine commander
and i'm gonna watch some submarine clips
and we're gonna rate them for realism
torpedo the americans are shooting at us
again pitch is too high
the torpedo's rushing
yes you can tell what kind of torpedo it
is by the sound that it makes and all
different torpedoes
have slightly different sounds so one of
the things we do is study all those
different sounds to help us out
con stone our new contacts here 4-1
alpha-class soviet submarine
alpha-class soviet submarine that sends
shivers up my spine
the alpha was this crazy submarine that
the russians built
back in the 70s people were trying all
kinds of different things they had a
titanium haul
they used liquefied lead to cool the
reactor if you can imagine such a thing
it was the fastest deepest diving
submarine ever basically
it's like a miata with a corvette engine
it was a crazy submarine
the weapon enabled on the far side of
the target it passed red october before
an arm
if you turn your torpedo on too far out
there because you're trying to get as
close as possible and you overshoot
you missed pelican more speed
you're already running 110 and give me
115
no you don't do 115 on the reactor you
do 100
0.0 they didn't shoot at us i can't
attack a soviet submarine without
authorization
that's right rules of self-defense don't
let you do that
you see how sean connery and scott glenn
playing the two submarine commanders
they're like cool as cucumbers these
guys are within a few seconds of maybe
getting
blown to bits this is exactly the way
submarine commanders are
you're heading straight into that
torpedo
[Applause]
it's a highly unlikely maneuver to
to actually work especially twice and
the torpedoes never be that close
together so
that i loses some credibility but
overall the sense of
uh not really knowing what's going on
the sense of having to make decisions
the sense of this cat and mouse is all
really good
when i was joined the submarine force i
didn't come from a military family my
mom's like what do you do
and i'm like when this movie came out
like mom watch this movie this will tell
you
eight out of ten
[Music]
uh we don't use glass on a submarine
like that and that's why
considering these guys just drove into
the bottom they're in pretty good shape
unfortunately we kind of know what this
looks like because in 2005
a u.s nuclear submarine did hit the
bottom
this was a glancing blow 98 of the 135
people on board
suffered some sort of injury it was very
bloody on the submarine a lot of
contusions broken bones and this would
be much worse than that because they're
going straight down
they're going straight into the bottom
and so i think
letting everyone sort of be okay yeah
we saw some people bumping around but
basically everyone's okay afterwards
of course you can't have a movie if
everyone dies that's the end of the
movie
uh the sense of what it's like when you
turn vertical though that's pretty good
so i'm gonna give it a six out of ten
you don't want to do this by the way on
your submarine
why that torpedo just fell over kind of
that easy it looked like there was a
cable cut
these things are strapped down on
multiple straps it's really hard to
dislodge them and then the other thing
is
what they're showing here is pretty
accurate it takes a lot for the weapon
to go off
and the thing falls and bounces the
weapon's not going to go off you hit it
with a hammer the weapon's not going to
go off
you heat it up the weapon's not going to
go off these things are designed
so that it takes a very specific
sequence of
operations to make the actual warhead go
up
so these are torpedoes with the classic
propeller on the back and they're
designed to go sync other ships
or submarines submarines also can carry
missiles that can attack land targets
and missiles that can attack
other ships and also mines that would
lie in wait
for the bad guy it only takes one of
these modern torpedoes
to sink all but the very largest
warships it's a space that
every crew member on the submarine would
have access to and would be
knowledgeable about
the reason is because if there's some
sort of a casualty we need to muster the
entire crew
to go fight it the the philosophy on a
submarine is one crew
one fight so with very few exceptions
the entire crew has access to the entire
ship i'm going to give it a 7 out of 10.
the engine room is sparkly now this
scene from the simpsons
sends shivers up my spine because this
is the worst
fear of all submariners flooding at deep
depths the water comes in very very
quickly and you don't need to flood the
entire submarine here's what happens
let's say there's water in the front
part of the submarine that part of the
submarine starts to get heavier
and then the submarine starts to tip
down like this which means that the
water
in the submarine rushes more towards the
front
and it makes it even heavier and tips
down even more and so what happens is
now the sub
you end up like this and when you're
like this your ballast tanks don't work
anymore you can't
blow the the use the air to blow the
water out
because the air will just go out the
side this is how you die in a submarine
and
if you saw the movie titanic that's how
that
ship sank and you remember at the end
end of the movie as the ship was sinking
the titanic was rising up and that's
because the water was cascading
from compartment to carbon to
compartment it's called the free
service effect and that's that's how you
die on a submarine it's not
pretty
[Music]
now if you're taking on water like these
guys are the first thing
you're going to want to do is come as
shallow as possible that does two things
for you number one
the pumps that are pumping off the water
have less pressure to pump against so
you're pumping off faster and
the water coming in has less pressure
behind it easiest way to stop flooding
in a submarine
because most of the water inside a
submarine is coming in through pipes is
we have these valves that we can shut
isolate the system
now here it looks like it's next to a
tank or maybe even the hole
in that case it's a very very difficult
problem because
when you get a leak that water is
spraying in so hard it's harder than any
water
cannon you have ever seen and they show
it here it's trickling in like a limp
garden hose there's no way so you're
pushing against the pressure
to put an earring pin in there no
the most realistic thing in this whole
scene is the guy underwater drinking
beer so i gotta give him like at least a
three though
we're trying from here
to here which means we are on one of
these two ridges
or we'd be crushed yeah now these charts
are very accurate you can see they have
contour lines
and for a body of water like the black
sea which
we've humans have operated in for a long
time it's probably very well mapped this
that's probably accurate no the black
seas are noxic
at depth no oxygen
yeah the black sea is a very special
body of water
it's basically like a bathtub and has
very little interaction and you have
rivers flowing into it and then that
flows out to the mediterranean so
deep there's a layer where the deeper
water
is anoxic there's very very little
oxygen and as a result
there's little decay now i'm not sure
it's perfectly preserved
but it's just like finding human remains
in bogs they're very well
preserved whether they can use the drive
shaft or not i don't know
but still overall nine out of ten for
realism
that's true we have rules that are not
open to interpretation personal
intuition
gut feelings hairs on the back of your
neck we're all very well aware of what
our orders are and what those orders
mean
this is exactly right you want to side
with denzel
but what gene hackman is saying right
here is exactly right these guys are
trained on this a hundred times
including
the exact kinds of errors that they're
seeing right now but then
he takes it too far bob arrest this man
and get him out of here under operating
procedures governing the release of
nuclear weapons we cannot launch our
missiles unless both you
and i agree that's right so denzel
doesn't need to get in a big argument he
just needs to say i'm not going to
announce that
the rest of the crew knows the procedure
is if they don't
hear both voices those missiles aren't
going to fly
gene hackman doesn't have the right to
remove him from his position because he
doesn't agree with him it's set up so
that two
people independently have to make the
decision to launch nuclear weapons it's
such a huge deal
now this is all just uh fantasy that
some
hollywood people dreamed up first of all
it's not mutiny because denzel's not
collaborating with it with anybody it's
just
he's by himself mutiny would mean he has
a whole bunch
of or at least one other person with him
denzel
can't relieve the captain just because
he doesn't agree with
with the captain's decision commanding
officers can get relieved
for for example a medical reason he's
incapacitated and
having a disagreement about something is
not
a legitimate reason for
relieving your commanding officer no one
would follow that order
i'm gonna give it like uh four out of
ten
so that's kind of what it would look
like now the reason they have to
practice this
is because a world war ii submarine
spends a lot of time on the surface it's
really more of a submersible because
they have diesel engines
and they need oxygen nuclear submarines
we spend almost all of our time
underwater so let's say you're on the
surface steaming along and also when
someone sees an airplane coming toward
you
you got to get underwater very very very
quickly so what's happening is the
people on the bridge
are coming down from the bridge now the
hatch is open but at the same time we're
opening the vents
and flooding the submarine and tipping
it deep you got to get the hatch shut
before the water level comes up to that
level or all of a sudden you're going to
start taking flooding so it's a very
highly choreographed and synchronized
event
this is a 10 out of 10. this is exactly
what it would have been like
watch submerge ship to 160 feet so you
see here the submarine spends as little
time on the surface as possible
submariners are allergic
to sunlight the whole point of being a
submarine is to stay under underwater
they pop up at the very last minute and
as soon as they get the seal team on
board which they do very rapidly
shut the hatch and submerge the ship
again here's the thing in war
if you can be seen you can be targeted
if you can be targeted you can be shot
if you can
be shot you can be killed so the best
way to break that chain of events
is at the very beginning overall i'm
going to rate this a 7
out of 10 for realism
the reactor repair has failed
at any moment we could have an explosion
which could set off the warheads
no reactors don't explode this
unfortunately is perpetuating a myth
that
we have to fight in nuclear power which
is that reactors are somehow like
nuclear weapons and that reactor is
going to explode like nuclear weapons
can so first of all the reactor is not
going to explode
secondly within their power it might
melt down but it's not going to explode
if it exploded the chance of
igniting detonating secondary weapons
zero because the other weapons are
designed
not to go off just because there's
another explosion
nearby this would destroy the american
ship
only a few kilometers
from the nato base it wouldn't set off
the warheads because the warheads are
designed
not to detonate unless their detonation
sequence goes through you can't
if you blow up a warhead it doesn't also
blow up the chance that they'd be so
close that if their warheads went off it
would
destroy the other ship or the nato base
again
highly highly highly improbable
we could dive and attempt to repair the
reactor
now what does diving have to do with
repairing the reactor
you just repair the reactor wherever you
are so i mean they don't really have
much of a choice here either they
don't try and fix a reactor and risk an
explosion or they
try and fix the reactor so it's not like
there's a whole
debate here but i'm going to rate this
as 0 out of 10
because not only is it totally
unrealistic but it perpetuates
some of the unhelpful myths about
nuclear power
this is the navy we're commanding
officers a mighty and
terrible thing don't you dare see what
you said to the boys back there again
i don't know yeah this is a command
philosophy thing now i'll tell you
i like to say i don't know because what
it does is it invites thinking from the
crew
when captain sullenberger landed his
airplane the the airbus on the hudson
river one of the last things that he
said to the co-pilot was hey you got any
ideas
what you want is everyone on board and
thinking now maybe in an extreme
crisis you don't want me you don't want
to act like you don't really know what's
going on
but 99.999 percent of the time
saying i don't know saying what do you
think that's really good thing
you're the skipper now and the skipper
always knows what to do whether he does
or not
the official title for the captain of a
submarine is commanding officer or
ceo or sometimes captain that's a very
common thing but here harvey keitel
refers to matthew mcconaughey as skipper
that comes from an
old german dutch word that's based on
ships skip
skipper another term for the captain
is a little less fun
it's called the old man and they might
refer to the captain as the old man
because typically the captain was the
oldest person on the ship now you'll
notice they're wearing different
uniforms and
the idea it comes from back in world war
ii
the submarines because they're so tight
and so claustrophobic
they're a little less formal than the
surface ships and the men
tended to take some liberties with their
uniforms
this is pushing it a little bit on
modern submarines what you're going to
find
is everyone is looking very professional
we have common uniforms
and they're designed to protect us from
fires and things like that so we take
these uniforms uh very seriously because
they could
end up saving our lives i'm gonna give
it an eight
out of ten
doctor yeah so this is the first
question we're prepared to catalyze
catalyze
what submarines don't have weapons to
shoot down other missiles they have
weapons to shoot down
ships and other submarines
what yeah that's an incredible weapon
but not that incredible if these
missiles are the size
of small school buses they're flying at
a thousand miles an hour
they're this far away coming this way at
the submarine you put a hundred bullets
in that thing and
in in two seconds it's still going to go
right through the submarine
crazy multiple issues with tactics
the physics of the thing don't really
work i don't think any submarine
commander would
act that way i love the movie but it's
not realistic i'm gonna give it a three
out of ten
[Music]
yeah i don't think so here's the problem
sound does not
transmit well between a big interface
like the water
to the air so you can stick your head
under water and you can hear
say you can hear whales and stuff then
you put your head in the air
you don't hear him anymore and the
reverse is true sound that's in the air
doesn't transmit into the water if he
were drumming on the side of the ship
the side of that little row boat and
that rowboat was
transmitting the noise into the water
then yeah i could hear that but it
wouldn't have the fidelity
that these guys are listening to good
movie but this scene not so realistic
5 out of 10 for this particular scene
mr ware set up charges to 100.
yeah so in world war ii none of these
weapons were guided you had to drive
directly over the enemy submarine
and launch your depth charges hopefully
setting them to the right depth
he's turning so he's listening to the
sonar
and and when you have two propellers
those destroyers have two propellers
and so when a ship starts to turn what
happens is the water pressure is
different and so two propellers get a
little out of sync so instead of going
it's like and you can hear that
and that's what the submarine captain
there was listening to
so the destroyer went over and now it
wants to come back
but it has to turn and at that point
it's very broad
that's the point of maximum
vulnerability i'm gonna give this an
eight out of ten for world war world war
two submarine versus destroyer
combat look like there's no way so
you're pushing against the pressure
to put an earring pin in there no
the most realistic thing in this whole
scene is the guy underwater drinking
beer